it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week Blizzard releases all the
loot you can carry from help with Diablo
3 ultimate evil edition the console
exclusive package that includes the
Reaper of souls expansion on current and
old gen consoles all launch day copies
of the ultimate evil edition come
packaged with a code for infernal
pauldrons shoulder plates and you're not
going to want to be the only one of your
friends without those shoulders wings so
that's against the rules and you can't
sit with us it's got four player
multiplayer local or online and if you
ever play diablo 3 on last gen your
saves carry over so get it while it's
hot August nineteenth also this week
it's a bunch of sneaking skull King
tiptoeing and infiltrating with
counterspy this side-scrolling cover
based shooter gives you top grade
weapons to infiltrate super secret faces
preventing nuclear war of course and
presumably getting the girl hi I'm
plenty but of course you are it's shaken
up on three platforms but not stirred
for anyone but Sony you can start
sleeping August nineteenth North America
and Europe get a few titles this week
that were previously released in Japan
for ps3 owners tales of eggs Ilya gets a
well-earned sequel and your back is Luud
ger with the task of destroying
alternative timelines to keep the world
in balance Vita gets two titles from the
SAO series infinity moment and hollow
fragment so if you want to find out what
happens to kirito and asuna and that
weird little kid they found you'll have
to pick it up on the 19th let's talk
about death baby because hotline Miami
rampages it's way too
console this week to spill some ps4
blood murder gang members with shotguns
Uzis pool stick cues and your midst
pulsating music that between your age
your mask comes on you guessed it August
nineteenth plants vs zombies garden
warfare has been on pc xbox one and 360
for some time now but this week it
arrives on both playstation consoles the
ps4 version will also include boss mode
a feature previously exclusive to the
Xbox one version of the game take on dr.
zomboss and crazy day of August
nineteenth for further details visit
gamespot's new releases page release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change see you next week
I